thanks everyone for being here um
welcome to the last day of pi data
global for the next 30 minutes we will
be talking about active preference
learning and optimization under
uncertainty
so let's jump right into it
first of all who am i my name is quan
i'm a phd student and my research
focuses on bayesian methods in machine
learning and decision making under
uncertainty so that's the big umbrella
that our talk falls under so i'm pretty
excited to be here um i also sometimes
write about python programming and you
can find some of my books online
including advanced python programming
and the statistics and calculus workshop
here are my social media links if you go
to my github
profile under the talk through
repository you'll be able to find all of
the code that i use to generate the
plots that we'll be seeing throughout
this talk and there's also a link to the
slide deck that we'll be looking at
also just a quick note um if i do badly
on time we might not have time for
questions during the talk so feel free
to add me in this talks channel on uh
slackworkspace my
username just kwongwin my name so um
yeah definitely if we don't have enough
time for questions definitely let me
know on that slack
channel so with that let's get started
so i want to spend a couple of slides
motivating the problem that we are
solving which is black box preference
optimization under uncertainty and um
this is a very common problem the
general setup is um
when you have a combination of
parameters you want to tune and you want
to optimize a user's preference function
for example if you're a facebook or
media as they just recently changed
their name
you might want to change to tune the
frequency at which you display ads to
your users new news feed
so that you maximize the probability of
them clicking on an ad a completely
different example is if you're a 3d
animator and you're working with a
client and you're tasked with creating a
very expensive
3d rendering of an object and you have
some parameters to tune such as the
smoothness or the coloring of the object
so have you
so you have to find the best combination
for those parameters to uh meet your
client's expectation
and it doesn't have to be um
product recommendation company trying to
optimize your preference either it could
just be you trying to optimize some
process some
procedure on your own um a
fairly common example here is optimizing
some recipe for a dish or for a drink
and
finding the best amount of sugar to put
in coffee will be the example that we
will be coming back
during this talk
so formally the setup of this problem is
that we are given access to a user's
preference function f
which we also sometimes call the
objective function that is defined on
some domain d
and our goal is to find the
global optimum of the function x star
here that maximizes f over the domain
but there are a couple of challenges
that we have to face the first is that f
doesn't have an analytical form or
sometimes we don't have access to it so
don't we don't know
how the um generating the process of um
the function values f of x is being
generated
and another challenge is that obtaining
function values is expensive either in
terms of time or money or some other
safety critical condition
another unique challenge that is the
defining feature of this preference
optimization problem is that function
evaluations only come in the form of
pairwise comparisons
um so
the user doesn't actually rate a product
they are presented to presented to on a
scale but instead they are presented to
with a pair of products and they have to
report back to us which one they prefer
more so in this example
they presented um
with two products x1 and x2 in the
domain then if they prefer x1 over x2
they would say f of x1 is greater than f
of x2
we see that this preference
this pairwise comparison data is more
natural and easier to survey than
real value ratings and indeed research
has shown that humans are way better at
comparing items rather than rating them
on a scale
and we can come back to this example of
um trying to find the best recipe for
coffee say um our preference might
change day from day to day so um our
real value rating for specific for a
given cup of coffee
might change from uh
between today or tomorrow or the the day
after
but we can be fairly confident that um
if we prefer this one cup of coffee over
the other then that might that will stay
very consistent
and this is the exact problem that some
product recommendation
researchers and engineers run into where
they ask their users to rate the product
on a scale and they have to assume for a
considerable level of noise but if we
design our system so that it can handle
this kind of preferential pairwise
comparisons then we can be more
confident in the quality of the data
that we are collecting but we could also
reduce the cognitive burden
from the user which is also a nice added
bonus
so the real question is how could we
design such a system so that it could
work with pairwise comparisons and help
us identify the best product that
maximizes a user's preference and that's
what we will be
learning to do in this talk
so how does this look a big picture we
will start out with a machine learning
model that could be trained on pairwise
comparisons and we will use this model
to suggest new products to the user
after analyzing the product the user
will report back to us their preference
in the form of pairwise comparisons
and then we will add this new data point
to our running training data set and the
model will be updated upon this data set
again the goal here is to find the
best product that maximizes the use of
the user's preference and we repeat the
whole procedure until we reach some
termination condition
we will be focusing on two main
components the first is the machine
learning model that can learn from
preferential data
as well as the mechanism we use to
suggest new products to the user which i
typically call the optimization policy
all right so to make our discussions
more concrete we will be using a running
time example
the question we ask ourselves is how
much sugar should we put in a cup of
coffee so that we maximize our
preference
so in this case the function f the
objective function denotes our utility
while drinking a cup of coffee with x
grams of sugar in it
um
health experts claim that we should not
have more than 25 grams of sugar in a
cup of coffee so that would be our
domain from 0 to 25. note here that f is
just a one-dimensional function where x
is the amount of sugar but if we have
more parameters to tune in this
procedure for example if we want to
jointly tune for the amount of milk to
put
as well then it would be a
two-dimensional objective function but
again we are we assume that we are only
working with sugar for now so it's a
one-dimensional function
so what does this f look like it could
be plotted as a graph where the x-axis
is the amount of sugar and the y-axis is
our utility
if you have a sweet tooth then your
utility might linearly increase with
respect to x and your preference is
optimized with maximum x in this case
it's 25. um if you have the opposite
preference then your utility might
decrease with respect to x
for most people the utility is optimized
at some location in the middle and as
you move further away from this location
your utility will decrease
for some other people yeah that utility
might look even more complicated with
many local optima so in this example
this person prefers five grams of sugar
or 20 grams of sugar over the other
the other points in the domain
we will be using this function as the
true objective function that that we are
optimizing when we come back to this
example later on but again in our
setting we assume that we don't know
what this function f looks like and our
goal is still trying to find the x star
that maximizes it over the domain using
only pairwise comparisons
at this point i should stop for any
immediate questions but i'm running low
on time so please note down your
questions on slack or maybe on zoom
okay so moving on with the talk
remember in our learning loop we have
two components that we need to design
the first is the machine learning model
that learns from pairwise comparison
data
in this case we will use a gaussian
process or a gp
overall a gp defines a distribution over
functions and it generalizes the concept
of a normal distribution for a random
variable to functions
so how does this work visually
usually we start out with a constant gp
across the whole domain before observing
any data the solid line here is the mean
function and the shaded region is the
confidence interval
and the way we usually read this plot is
if we were to take a vertical slide of
the plot at any given point we will
obtain the
normal distribution representing a
belief about the function value at that
point so for example if we care about
what f of seven is what we should do is
to take a vertical slide of a plot at
seven
and
that and we will obtain a normal
distribution where the mean of the
distribution is the intersection of the
vertical slice with the mean function
here mu
and the standard deviation is simply
half of the confidence interval
i see that's one question in the chat um
the moderator please
let me know when we um
when we start for questions later sure
thanks for the question
um
okay so at this point we haven't
observed any data yet so the um the gp
is just constant everywhere so nothing
interesting is happening
um
if you have worked with a gp before you
might know that with real value data
such as
some f of x is equal to some y then we
can efficiently update we can update a
gp exactly but remember that in our
setting we are working with pairwise
comparisons so our data actually comes
in this form
unfortunately a gp cannot be exactly
updated on this kind of data
but in bayesian statistics there's a
trick called a plus approximation that
could help us with this
we will not be going into the math of
laplace approximation but the idea is
um
first we compute the probability of the
data that we are observing so for in
this case we are observing this data
point and we are computing the
probability of f 3 is greater than of
12.
and what we do with the plus
approximation is to manually tweak the
gp so that it maximizes this probability
visually it will look something like
this pretend that again we are starting
out with a constant gp that's just zero
everywhere for the mean function and we
observe this data point that we've been
looking at f of three is greater than f
of 12. if we update the gp the new model
will look something like this using
laplace approximation
where the mean function has
changed a little bit
so that it now has a slightly negative
slope
to represent the fact that f of 3 is
greater than other 12. let's look at for
more data points
let's pretend that now we observe f of
12 is less than f of 20 so the new gp
updates to this model
if we also observe that f of
3 is less than f of 20 then now the new
model becomes this
what's really interesting i think about
this is that the mean function
absolutely
obeys all these preferential ordering of
in the training data that we have
f of 3 is indeed greater than f of 12
here f 12 is indeed lower than f of 20
and f 3 is also lower than f 20 here
which is very nice
but we also see that the confidence
interval in the around these data points
these three data points have shrunk a
little bit to represent the fact that we
have learned something about the
function values of these three data
points
um i just want to remember um oh and at
this point our
trick with a vertical slice 2 are still
applied if we care about f of 7 again
then we take a vertical slide of the gp
at 7 and note down the intersection with
the mean function and the confidence
interval and that will give us a normal
distribution now an updated normal
distribution representing our updated
belief about f seven
again at this point i just want to
re-emphasize the fact that this gp is a
very nice mathematical object that we're
working with whose mean function
conveys all the preferential ordering
that we have in the training data
but um it also offers a calibrated
quantification of uncertainty
which is very important for the
downstream optimization task which we
will discuss later and
this quantification of uncertainty is
what sets the gp apart from other point
estimate model such as a neural network
or a decision tree
okay um i think i'm still running a bit
low on time but thank you for the
questions we definitely get to those
questions later but for now let me just
quickly move on to the second part of
the talk where we talk about
optimization policies where we use the
gp model we have to make new
recommendation of new products to the
user
here this process is typically called
bayesian optimization because the model
that we're working with the gp is a
bayesian model
now a good bayesian optimization policy
should trade off between exploitation
and exploration
here is the gp that we have been looking
at so at each iteration of the learning
loop that we saw earlier we need to ask
ourselves the question whether we should
present to the user at some point where
we expect to have a high va
preference value such as this point over
here this corresponds to exploitation
or should we present to the user some
point that we don't know much about such
as this point over here where the
uncertainty is higher
this corresponds to expiration so we
need to balance between these two
aspects of the optimization
a natural approach is to appeal to the
concept of improvement
here the motivation is
the question how much do we expect to
improve from the current best point that
we have seen so far which we typically
call the incumbent y star if we were to
query the function value f of x at any
given location x
here improvement is defined to be this
quantity i of x
which is a fairly natural metric for
improvement
um if f of x is greater than y star the
incumbent the best point that we have
seen so far then this whole quantity
what i of x is equal to the difference
between f of x and y star um so we
improve by the difference if f of x is
less than y star however then this whole
quantity is zero so we don't improve by
the
we don't improve from the incumbent
so it's a
natural metric to measure income
the improvement that we could make but
note here that we don't actually know
what f of x is equal to so we don't have
a way to
exactly compute i of x
but thanks to the gp that we have f of x
actually follows normal distribution
with unknown
and standard deviation
so what we could do is we could compute
the expected value of i of x
very easily
visually it will look something like
this
because we care about
improvement from the incumbent we first
need to identify the incumbent which in
this case is this green point and we
only focus on the upper portion of the
gp
denoting the improvement that we expect
to make
then we compute this expected value
across the domain which again we can do
fairly easily
thanks to the normal distribution belief
we have which i'm showing here in the
bottom plot now the policy resulting
from this process which is typically
called the expected improvement policy
of the ei policy
will tell us to query this point that
maximizes the expected improvement score
in this case
so with this expected improvement policy
we have a way to
find a point to present to the user
in order to find um in order to find the
global optimum but remember in our
setting we need to present to the user a
pair of points so we need a way to
extend this
well the first natural way is to just
simply
extend our improvement measure to take
in
not one point but two points x1 and x2
here and the maximum is defined over the
incumbent f of x1 and f of
so we could do that as well this policy
is typically called ei2 but there's also
another natural way to extend the
the old ei policy and that is to compare
the point suggested by ei with the
current best point that we have seen the
incumbent
this is actually the strategy that
professional photographers use where
they take a lot of pictures of you and
they ask you to
compare the picture that you like the
best so far with the remaining pictures
you can think of this as some sort of a
last
incumbent standing strategy where you
try to beat the incumbent with the
points suggested by ei
so this policy ei incumbent is the
second policy that we could use
so let's look at one
one visual um look at one example of how
ei incumbent works
let's pretend that in uh during the
optimization procedure this is the gp
that we are working with so um the whole
process starts where we compute the ei
score across the domain and we first
need to find the point that maximizes
the score which in this case is this
thread point
then we will ask the user to compare
this red point with the incumbent
that we the best point that we have seen
so far which is this green point now the
user who actually has this
orange object preference function that
is hidden away from us will tell us that
the green point is better than the red
point so we'll update our gp to this new
model using laplace approximation as we
have seen
now we repeat the whole process again
in a new iteration of the loop where we
compute the ei score find the point that
maximizes the score and ask the user to
compare it against the incumbent which
is this new green point now the user
will tell us that the red point is
better than the green point so we update
our model to this new gp
do this one more time compute the aei
score find the maximizer of this call
and ask the user to compare it against
the incumbent
and update your gp after observing their
pairwise comparison
now at this at this point we see that
our gp models the region around the
global optimum fairly well in terms on a
relative scale and in fact the maximizer
of the mean function around here
actually corresponds to
the maximizer of the true objective
function which is the global optimum
that we're trying to find
so just from this one example it seems
that what we're doing is working
but one example might not be enough to
convince us that this e i incumbent is
effective so i ran a couple of numerical
experiments where i benchmarked the
policies that we have across different
objective functions so really quickly
the procedure
is something like this for each
objective function that we will see each
policy will start out with the same
random data set and they each policy is
allowed to make the same number of
queries to the user which is just a
simulated article in our in my
experiments
and throughout this process i measured
the gap measure which is a like a common
metric in bayesian optimization we don't
really know what it is but we don't
really need to know what it is but it's
between zero and one and the higher it
is the better
and for robustness i also repeat each
experiment 10 times with a different
random initial data set so let's look at
some results here i compare ei2 and ei
and company against a
naive benchmark which is just a random
policy that uniformly
selects two points in the domain and
presented to the user
starting out with this
i'm sorry to interrupt you john until
now we just have one comment no
questions
but we have like three minutes more
so just okay i can remember
thanks for the reminder i'll try to wrap
this up real quickly um
so for this very um simple function
here on the right i'm showing the gap
measure again um
as a function of the number of queries
made to the user by the three policies
and remember that the higher the gap the
better so in this case all three
optimization policies are actually very
good
however if we switch to a slightly more
complicated um
true objective function with more local
optima
then
the difference between the two three
policies becomes clearer where
random policy becomes a bit worse and
ei2 emerges as the top performing policy
and overall ei2 is actually the top
performing policy for one-dimensional
objective functions
however as we move
to higher dimensional objective
functions in this case we have a
two-dimensional objective function then
the trend becomes a little bit more
complicated where random actually
completely fails at this optimization
test
it doesn't improve the gap at all and ei
incumbent takes over as a top performing
policy and the same trend continues for
other higher dimensional objective
functions as well
so at this point i think we've seen some
evidence suggesting that the two
policies that we have designed ea2 and
er incumbent are better than a benchmark
of randomly sampling and we have also
gained an interesting insight that ei2
is better for one-dimensional objective
functions while ei incumbent is better
for higher dimensional functions
so for the last part of the talk really
quickly i want to touch on some
practical considerations you might want
to know if and when you decide to
implement this procedure on your own use
cases
so the first of course is what open
source packages you could use the first
option that you have is gpro which is a
fairly lightweight extension of
scikit-learn and it uses as you can see
very friendly numpy syntax so it makes
it very easy for you to use if you're
familiar with numpy and it's called bass
also very small so
it's very easy for you to go in here and
dig around and see what's going on
underneath
but if you want a have more heavy duty
streamline option then botox would be
your best bet
it's developed by facebook i guess meta
at this point and um
it belongs to the pi torch g pytorch
ecosystem so
it has very extensive support not only
on this preference optimization
framework but other
bayesian optimization framework as well
i have 30 seconds left so i just want to
quickly mention some exciting
applications that you could apply this
preference optimization framework too
there are many applications such as
audio processing and image processing
an exciting application that i think is
really interesting is working with dip
generate deep generated models where you
have a latent space in the middle and
you can use
a deep model such as a variation or auto
encoder to generate objects so what you
could do is to apply bayesian
optimization on this slow dimensional
latent space and present to the users
generated reconstructed objects at the
end here
to collect that feedback real quick i'm
just going to show this gif here where
it's just a cool transition of the
optimization process where you present
images of fashion items to the user but
you can still optimize within a low
dimensional continuous space
and that is the end of my presentation
thank you for being here again and
i think my my time has run out so i'll
be happy to take any questions on slack